u.s troops have almost completed their
pull-out after a conflict that has cost
them
and the afghan people dearly afghan
civilians have suffered huge losses of
life
with more than 47 000 killed since 2001.
while the afghan government keeps the
army's death toll secret
to avoid damaging morale estimates show
that between 66 069
000 afghan soldiers have also been
killed
more than 2 400 u.s soldiers and 455
uk soldiers and military personnel have
been killed in action
and the war has now cost an approximate
2.261
trillion dollars sky news has spent time
with the taliban in this exclusive
report
the team traveled from kabul to
sayadabad south west of the capital
and then to an old u.s army base at
sultan kell which has just recently been
taken over by the taliban
our special correspondent alex
crawford's report was filmed by kevin
shepard
the taliban are on the march and gaining
territory at an astonishing rate
we've been invited to meet them inside
their own base
they want to show us as foreign
journalists how strong they are
and also how they're in no mood to
compromise
the departure of the bulk of the
american and other nato forces has
emboldened them and they smell victory
one commander in warduk province told me
they would never work alongside the
other groups in government
as a real afghan we would never do that
because they are the people who are
killing and kidnapping
who are thieves and who are corrupt so
we'll never work with them
we're the first foreign journalists to
see the latest army base the taliban
have captured in the province
and they want to show us the treasure
trove of military riches they've seized
with it
many of these boxes supplied by the
americans hadn't even been
opened before the taliban got hold of
them
whoa
can anyone believe that the taliban
wants peace when you've you've got all
these weapons now
most of the time we don't rely on all of
this we just rely on allah
but it does help us a lot and it's given
us a lot of new weapons we can use in
battle
of course we want peace more people want
peace here but the government doesn't
want peace with us
from this base alone the taliban say
they seized about 900
guns 30 humvees and 20 army pickup
trucks
it's a whole pile of of destroyed
vehicles military vehicles there and a
huge area that they've managed to take
over
i think there's the taliban will see
this and view this as a substantial
victory
and it follows a nationwide pattern of
afghan soldiers putting up only a
half-hearted fight
many of the fighters we saw were
carrying new weapons
seized during the taking of the base
the white flag that signifies the
taliban takeover
is flying in large swathes of the
country right now
and they're creeping closer to the
capitol
our journey on route to the taliban was
halted this is a crucial
highway which the taliban had been
trying to get control of
the afghan army brought in
reinforcements to push them back
but the fact that the taliban have got
so close to
the capital showing them making gains
the taliban are winning the propaganda
war able to plant and detonate roadside
bombs
with few reassurances from the
government about how they're going to
regain control
instead in taliban controlled areas they
blamed the afghan national
army for injuries and insecurity
we saw no women at all out in public
although the taliban insist they've
progressed and want their girls
educated do you all welcome the taliban
being here
tell me why
because it's so much safer now the
taliban have brought us security
and peace he says
[Music]
the taliban paint themselves as deeply
religious
and say they're fighting for an islamic
emirate based on a strict interpretation
of sharia law
like so many others this former prisoner
jailed by the americans immediately
rejoined the fight on his release
the only thing that will persuade me to
put down my gun is if there's islamic
law here
based entirely on islam and the
government is run according to islamic
rules
the taliban resurgence appears to have
real momentum and that's worrying for
the afghan government and its
international
allies who are now watching all the
military hardware they handed over
ending up in the hands of the group
they're meant to be used against
the government is seen as weak and
deeply unpopular in areas
particularly where the taliban have
managed to take a hold
can you work with any of them they are
nothing anything
you're nothing and this we will destroy
three
we are we are going to
destroy our country they
they come they bring a bad
bad situation for afghans for our people
for our civilized for our country
for our schools for our
hospitals everything they're destroyed
and this while peace talks are meant to
be ongoing and all the while the taliban
seem to be growing
stronger and that will surely lessen
their desire to do
any deals alex crawford sky news in
wilduck province